Chicken nuggets
are a food I have never fed my kids before,
and that's because I prioritize their health over
convenience.
Nuggets may appear kid friendly and fun for the littles,
but nothing could be further from the truth.
What scares me the most is the quality of the chicken,
which comes from confined animal factory farms.
There fed a corn in soy diet and slaughtered as a young,
likely sick bird,
then processed with bleach to remove bacteria.
Other ingredients that scare me are MSG,
a salty flavor enhancer,
and the vegetable oils like canola,
corn, and soybean that they're fried in.
It's really pretty simple to make nuggets.
You just dunk the nugget pieces into batter of flour,
baking powder,
baking soda,
salt and pepper,
and sparkling water,
which give them an airy crunch.
Then frying quality oil like schmaltz
for about five minutes per side.
My homemade nuggets are high in protein and satisfying.
Dunk them in a good ingredient,
ketchup or homemade barbecue sauce.